bonjour 7,8 week-end le magazine dédié à
vos loisirs à vos sorties on fera
également un retour sur l'actualité de
cette semaine écoulée dans le courant de
l'émission parlera des initiatives
proposées par la mairie de plaisir avec
vous cyril bonsoir l'intitulé rires et
frissons de faire frissonner tout
peut-être qu'on vient sur quelques
instants mais d'abord donc ce week-end
c'est la solidarité qui est mise à
l'honneur avec le téléthon un seul
numéro de téléphone forcément vous le
connaissez c'est le 36 37
plusieurs manifestations sont organisées
ce vendredi et ce samedi et puis jeudi
en place sur le plateau du 7-8 l'actuel
le responsable de la section yvelines
est-ce du téléthon était présent ainsi
que le responsable du téléthon à magny
les hameaux
deux piliers de la manifestation si le
preuve si l'on peut dire on les écoute
combien d'années de mobilisation à vous
deux autour du téléthon depuis quand
pour 87
et pour vous ou à peu près dans les
mêmes eaux que cela n'est il pas assez
fort calcul moral pour calculer tout ça
le téléthon qui va débuter dès demain
travers la france vous allez organiser
les animations enfin forcément de
récolter des fonds peut peut-être juste
déjà évoqué le bilan de l'an dernier
comment ça s'était passé sur magny les
hameaux tout d'abord gagner l'une des
communes qui marche bien de très bonne
mobilisation
un bon chiffre à peu près constants par
rapport aux années précédentes c'était
au tour de vous avez encore à peu près
le chiffre en tête 30 1362 c'est assez
précis conserver c'était très bien
l'année dernière en a fait 4 126 milles
de 0,66 exactement pour 103 qu'entre un
jeu convention de communes et j'ai 109
contre 1 à l'heure actuelle donc
j'espère encore en avoir demain quels
sont les rendez-vous pas principaux et
surtout sont importants pour récolter
tous les bénévoles sont mobilisés mais
qu'elles sont ce les animations a parlé
ce soir
ben je vais dix ans notre village
d'accueil de saint rémy les chevreuse
donc qui se présente bien un village
d'accueil qui regroupe l'ensemble des
communes de navets enfin une partie de
l'ensemble des communes de la vallée de
chevreuse un focus sur magny les hameaux
vous avez toujours un parrain et une
marraine de prestige cette manière on a
une marraine effectivement une jeune
chanteuse qui est à malte et étaient
connus localement détecté à 4 ans un bel
espoir et pour douce et pas c'est un
symbole d'espoir 17 ans elle en a 10 à
17 ans et cela est le parrain jean luc
ettori
donc on en parle pour parler de lui en
ce moment
footballeur 6 ans 2 sélections
et puis bien évidemment dans notre
journal d'information de lundi en direct
à 18h on reviendra évidemment sur ce
téléthon de cette 2e week-end et vous
justement quel est votre programme pour
le téléthon c'est la question que nous
sommes allez vous poser le problème pour
le téléthon on en a pas particulièrement
mais nous on va regarder à la télévision
qui avec les enfants leur expliquer un
peu comme quel principe du téléthon pour
qu'ils aident un peu tout le monde en
grandissant aussi bas les danses des
enfants les danses anneaux et puis ça
fait déjà tout le week-end il ya
vendredi soir ma fille samedi après midi
nous plus hélas d'autres choses samedi
matin au niveau scolaire aubin j'en ai
pas encore programme pour lutter les
tout va peut être que j'irai à la salle
la barre des foyers 10 enveloppes à
prendre prendre les enveloppes
on boit quelque chose sur place et puis
voilà quoi je regarde un peu ce que ce
qui se passe mais non c'est vrai que j'y
fais pas très attention à dire écoutez
je suis bénévole au secours populaire
donc je vais tenir le stand samedi toute
la journée de 9 heures à 11 heures à 23
heures
voilà des habitants solidaires et ce
week end si vous cherchez une idée de
sortie fo propose le musée de la toile
de jouy c'est à jouy en josas à un musée
qui a été totalement rénové après six
mois de chantier les nouveaux intérieurs
ont été présentés ce jeudi soir le musée
abrité depuis 1991 dans le château de
l'églantine était fermé au public depuis
la mi juillet
les travaux ont permis de tout repenser
notamment des éclairages ouest un peu
sombre des vitrines plus adapté pour ne
pas abîmer les toiles de coton qui sont
extrêmement fragiles car certaines de
ses toiles ont plus de 200 ans les
collections permanentes ont été
renouvelées elles le seront
régulièrement tous les six mois car le
musée compte 6000 motifs dans ses
réserves
et là vous ne pouvez en découvrir qu'une
cinquantaine donc c'est à dire qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à voir et pour
compléter cette modernisation une
application pour tablette est dorénavant
disponible en français et en anglais
le musée de la toile de jouy rend
hommage vous l'avez vu il ya quelques
instants au créateur du fameux textile
qui était au beurre quand faubert quand
donc qui avait créé la manufacture à
jouy en josas
à la fin du xviiie siècle une magnifique
turquie a employé jusqu'à 1300 ouvriers
on va écouter justement la conservatrice
du musée qui nous parle de ce monsieur
oberkampf il invente ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la toile de jouy c'est à
dire ces grands textile imprimés de
scènes de pastorale monochrome sur fond
du tissu blanc ça c'est vraiment lui qui
l'a inventé et puis après ces motifs ont
été copiés par d'autres centres dédiés
nage en france mais c'est vraiment lui
qui l'a inventé et il a toujours aussi
pour toutes ces toiles exiger une
qualité telles que le nom toile de jouy
est devenu le terme générique pour ses
toiles là est-ce que oberkampf à par
rapport aux autres c'est que il a
toujours été à la pointe des inventions
à la fois techniques chimiques et
artistique qui suivait le progrès du
goût est il adapté toujours ses toiles à
la fois aux événements historiques mais
aussi au goût des arts décoratifs du
temps qui savait tout faire
il savait c'est un coloriste c'était un
graveur ça fait graver ses planches
c'était un dessinateur il a créé ses
premiers modèles tout seul un chef
d'entreprise un entrepreneur vraiment y
cumuler toutes les qualités
c'est grâce à ça qu'il a fait de son
entreprise la troisième entreprise en
fait de france à l'époque
voilà le très joli musée de la toile de
jouy c'est une vraie peur donc à
découvrir ce week-end
si vous voulez aller on va quitter
l'univers feutré des tissus de boire
quand un autre univers alors cyril
savina vous me l'avez dit vous allez
nous faire frissonner alors c'est à dire
frissonner de plaisir bon c'est le jeu
de mot est facile c'est parce que ça se
passe à plaisir
rires et frissonner sasso de l'important
c'est un programme qui est à découvrir
depuis ce mois de décembre et jusqu'à la
mois de février a fait jusque tout à
fait puisque la première semaine du mois
devrait donc autour du thème des
monstres et du fantastique c'est un
programme qui inclut plein de directions
votre direction de ce visionnaire des
bibliothèques les centres sociaux de la
ville de plaisir l'année dernière vous
aviez fait la même chose sur le thème
des super héros
et là c'est donc l'airé les frissons
alors je veux d'abord commencer par les
animations les plus proches notamment
cette fameuse nuit nuit rires et
frissons qui aura lieu le vendredi 13
décembre
sassine traits parfaits quand même la
date s'y prêtait forcément
inévitablement et notre envie première
c'était de proposer une soirée
spécifiquement au public adolescent et
adulte donc soirée pour public averti
bien évidemment ce qui va se passer
13 eh bien je vais pas tout vous
dévoiler en fait il y aura une
projection tout se déroule autour d'une
projection un film qui sera proposé donc
il s'agit de bienvenue à zombieland
zombies dans un site particulier c'est
le théâtre robert manuel et surtout
juste avant la cour des menus une cour
qui va être habillée
il fera nuit le public sera accueilli et
bien par des personnages dont il
pourrait éventuellement se méfier ils
sont peut-être sortie du film ils seront
là on sent qu'on a entendu crier autant
de théâtre robert manuel et j'envoie
faut avoir très peur fait c'est pas le
train fantôme et on va se faire quelques
frayeurs en tout cas ça c'est certain
verdict avertit ça veut dire que la
projection elle est réservée à des ans à
partir de quoi tout en outre à partir de
12 ans à partir de 10 ans assez
important absolument absolument c'est
une soirée spécifique il ya celle-ci
programmé pour le public adolescent
adulte et d'autres suivront pour que
tout le monde puisse avoir son petit
moment de plaisir de rires et frissons
avant de parler de ces séances cinéma
mais plutôt après les vacances de noël
donc je rappelle un au théâtre robert
manuel c'est vendredi 13 à 20 ans
l'entrée est libre mais il est important
de contacter notamment le service
jeunesse les centres sociaux pour pour
s'inscrire en ce moment au centre social
de la mosaïque il ya un atelier
d'animation dont clan de créer son petit
film
je sais pas s'il fera peur mais en tout
cas c'est l'idée effectivement de
découvrir de comprendre comment
fonctionne le cinéma fantastique donc à
travers cette allure cet atelier pardon
de stop motion réalisation image par
image avec la manipulation manipulation
de la pâte à modeler c'est l'idéal
bien évidemment et comme c'est un
atelier qui s'adresse à des enfants
eh bien ça leur permet à la fois de
manipuler et puis de construire une
histoire la mettre en image de la filmer
et puis ce sera proposé le court métrage
réalisé sera proposé présenté aux
plaisirs roi le 8 février ils se
débrouillent bien les petits quand ils
sont comme ça ils sont meilleurs que
nous les adultes un autre toujours
toujours toujours ce vol contre nous ils
sont au delà nous l'avait dit ça sera
projeté au théâtre d'un ballet 8 février
sont les vivres le court métrage qui
fera peur ou pas peur maintenant en tout
cas qui qui a été réalisé par des petits
plaisirs voit alors l'est le premier
atelier les ateliers encore deux dates
d'ateliers mercredi 11 et mercredi 18
c'est ce que c'est encore possible de
venir faire j'en en ont le groupe est
constitué du groupe est constitué
effectivement l'idée c'est de participer
à toutes les étapes et d'aboutir de
faire aboutir cet atelier donc on
commence et on va jusqu'au bout jusqu'au
bout alors c'est un groupe restreint
mais qui va s'appliquer en tout cas à
construire quelque chose de très très
très très très concret très visuel et
puis voilà on découvrira alors là on
voit les effectifs
les images de cet atelier il ya un petit
groupe très compact en tout cas une de
nos journalistes le n 13 est allé se
rendre compte sur place de cet atelier
on va regarder tout de suite ce
reportage c'est sur l'atelier animations
mêlés aux jedi et ils sont les acteurs
un film fantastique
sept enfants du centre social et de la
bibliothèque de plaisir participent à
l'atelier stop motion
l'objectif réaliser des animations avec
des petits monstres en pâte à modeler et
les intégrer dans un court métrage
couleurs flat avec cet atelier stop
motion
les enfants découvrent comment on fait
du cinéma à travers la technique
d'animation image par image les photos
prises les unes après les autres sont
mises bout-à-bout et anime les petits
monstres
deux intervenants d'une association
parisienne ou imaginer le scénario et
apporte les techniques de cinéma alors
en gros ça raconte
un groupe d'enfants qui va suivre une
personne de l'entretien qui est là
depuis un certain temps mais
curieusement qui disparaît dans les
couloirs et en fait cette personne a une
espèce de boîte magique qui en fait une
porte tridimensionnel sur une dimension
parallèle il ya des enfants qui va
suivre le
la personne de l'entretien et qui va
disparaître dans le carton donc en fait
ses copains vont tenter d'essayer de le
retrouver et lui arrive à communiquer
de l'autre dans cette dimension en
déplaçant des objets donc c'est pour ça
qu'on est en train actuellement des
places et des lettres
moi je suis un peu comme médium je vois
ce qu'il se passe je sens des choses est
en fête
martin il est dans un monde parallèle et
enfermé et moi des fois je l'entends
dire elle moi il n'ya rien mes choix qui
m'a capturé le film sera projeté au
théâtre robert manuel a plaisir en
février prochain
voilà ce adorable ces minots comme son à
fond dedans
forcément on forcément à thème comme
celui ci les porteurs les monstres le
fantastique
voilà alors les super-héros l'année
dernière démontrent qu'il faut les il
faut avoir l'imagination elles
trouveront on trouvera je crois que
cette synergie entre ces directions
créer un dynamisme fou et les idées ne
manquent pas donc on trouvera en 3 alors
mais c'est pas fini donc là on a parlé
de ce qui se passait au mois de décembre
on va parler de ce qui va se passer
après les vacances de noël puisque les
animations danses pensé jusqu'au mois de
février alors là à la fois des séances
de cinéma des jeux de société des contes
musicaux
oui plein de choses plein de choses
plein de choses alors on mange à l'oeil
et tous programmés pour lui je vais
aller très vite mais on enchaîne le 31
le 31 janvier alors une soirée cinéma
encore encore une avec l'assistant du
vampire qui sera projeté on attend
public déguisé
et puis dans la semaine qui suit c'est
la semaine principal on concentre nos
animations sur le thème des rendez-vous
fantastique
on aura alors à la fois une exposition
on aura des contes musicaux pour les
plus petits
ça c'est aussi un moment très
sympathique une grande journée de jeu
une grande journée jo et d'épreuves
monstre en compagnie ou là ce sont des
monstres qui sont arrivés dans notre
monde et qui nous défient donc il va
falloir les renvoyer chez eux parce
qu'on n'a pas envie de les garder passé
la semaine
et puis le samedi qui termine en tout
cas cette manifestation samedi lui
février c'est l'occasion alors pour les
plus petits parce qu'il en faut pour
tous aussi bas de d'avoir leur petit ans
de prison c'est ce que je disais devant
le dessin animé d'animation tels
transylvanie et puis de profiter de
découvrir le court métrage qui a été
réalisé et fabriqué des masques dont
quelque chose de très très content la
grosse groff pendant qu'on parle oui oui
ça c'est augustine augustine à
l'échappée je pense qu'elle sera
présente vendredi 13
elle ne sera pas seule alors si vous
voulez avoir peur et frissonner de peur
et de plaisir à plaisir rendez vous
vendredi 13 donc au théâtre robert
manuel sociaux de la direction jeunesse
et avec quelques surprises
alors voilà surtout pas oublier de venir
chercher en tout cas le lait les billets
qui les billets qu'ils vont bien parce
que ce sont des places limitées et puis
et puis et puis
dernière petite chose quand même pour
donner vraiment l' envie d'être présent
ce soir là
si je vous dis ils ont dit si je vous
dit michael jackson voilà enfin rendez
vous est pris pour vendredi 13 on va
danser en plusieurs fois répété non pas
de danse à la merci vous conserver notre
calme en créole ne me sens pas tes cette
version merci en fin de semaine dernière
la mairie de trapped en partenariat avec
la librairie du millefeuille organisait
l'opération graines de culture l'idée
troquer des livres contre des graines et
les graines contre des livres
explications olivier magny calme
comme liliane qui est venu échanger ses
livres contre des oeillets à delta
ils étaient plus d'une cinquantaine
vendredi à la librairie le millefeuille
de trappes pour participer à l'opération
graines de culture le principe est
simple sous forme de troc chacun peut
échanger soit des livres contre des
graines soient des graines contre des
livres en résumé troqué de la culture
contre de la culture 22 culture à la
base ça vient du projet des jardins
partagés
donc c'est la mairie qui envisage depuis
depuis deux trois ans à mettre des
jardins partagés dans la ville de
trappes
l'idée c'était de donc d'aménager un
jardin pour de la culture et en même
temps de créer un événement culturel
ouvert à tous une fois par mois
c'est un échange et puis c'est vrai que
parfois quand on va dans les magasins
c'est ça c'est cher relativement cher et
donc nos moyens nous permettent pas
toujours de pouvoir l'acheter les
plantes qu'on voudrait si les livres
récupérer vont venir alimenter la
bibliothèque les graines et les bulbes a
mené par les participants serviront à la
culture du premier jardin partagé de la
ville de trappes un jardin de dix
emplacements basé sur le site de la
librairie et qui propose encore cinq
places disponibles avis aux amateurs
alors un père noël est ce que ça descend
forcément de la cheminée et bien non
vous allez pouvoir vous en rendre compte
du côté de maurepas un père noël qui a
toujours la cote chez les petits aussi
chez les grands carcan vieillot n 13
ce week end à la verrière le père noël
n'est pas descendu de la cheminée les
deux cette cour d'immeuble logique ce
n'est pas encore noël
alors pour faire patienter les enfants
jusqu'au 25 décembre
il est allé à leur rencontre avec son
panier devant les sens que j'ai besoin
de palau
oui la chatte endurer succès garanti
petits et grands scandent son nom et
piétinent d'impatience
yattara qui viennent pour vous oui j'ai
été bien sage en tout cas pour
satisfaire tout le monde le père noël a
même dû faire appel à son assistance
parmi la foule des enfants mais aussi
des parents et même notre journaliste et
yolan thorez qui elle non plus n'a pas
su résister mais bon faut aussi ou pas
c'est vrai je mérite
le père noël a fini sa tournée dans le
centre ville telle une star il a
multiplié les poses photos et les
rencontres avec son public et il pense
savoir d'où vient ce succès un look
l'entretenir eu beaucoup de travail
pas si facile la vie de père noël comme
chaque année à quelques semaines de noël
armée de liste les clients affluent dans
les magasins de jouets alors que vont
que vont être les cadeaux préférés à des
enfants éléments de réponse dans les
rayons si les parents en ont assez de
laisser leur smartphone à leurs enfants
ils peuvent désormais être tranquille
la génération dite y maîtrise à la
perfection les tablettes numériques et
les plus précoces vont pouvoir les
prendre en main partir d'un os de nos
ventes avantage c'est que ça concentre
quand même plein d'activités qu'on peut
retrouver sur plein de plein de support
différent puisqu'il ya du coloriage il
ya des activités créatrices du manuel et
aussi du mythique de l'apprentissage des
leçons même puisque vous avez vous avez
plein de possibilités pour pour
travailler le français les mathématiques
sur ce genre de l'appareil et c'est pas
connectée internet pour ce modèle là par
exemple en particulier donc ya pas de
risque
toujours aussi moderne ces figurines
peuvent se connecter au jeu vidéo grâce
à leur socle
chez les demoiselles les poupées à la
mode vampire reste très prisé mais il va
falloir choisir
si on l'écoutait ils prendraient tous
donc du coup on a pris un à varier en
fonction ballaman légaux dans le type de
les thèmes différentes qu'il est un peu
tôt pour railler mepha chaque boîte dans
cet autre grand magasin retour au succès
des années 90 cette célèbre peluches
animées déjà le produit le plus vendu au
mois de novembre mais il y a quinze ans
se jouait interactif doit être traité
avec grand soin et son jeune
propriétaire va même pouvoir lui
apprendre une autre langue
ces petits monstres qui ont
manger on s'en occupe on lui apprend à
parler à ce que nous y parle serbie et
après vous apprendre à parler français
donc ses enfants adorent pour faire face
à la demande ses magasins de jouets ont
doublé leurs effectifs pour aider le
père noël a apporté tous les cadeaux
sous le sapin le mois de décembre
représente environ 40% de leur chiffre
d'affaires annuel
peut-être allez-vous profiter du
week-end pour vous rendre dans les
salles de cinéma quels sont les films
qui vous ont le plus intéressé et le
diwan est allé recueillir vos avis à la
sortie des salles très bon dessin animé
de walt disney au dur pur jus et le
problème c'était vraiment très très bien
c'était bien j'aimais bien les chansons
les physiques et jerry c'est bien
réalisé beaucoup de chansons de musique
et voilà c'était très sympa qu'on a bien
aimé c'est très bien les nez d'un client
est un peu peur mais on annonce qu'on
apprécie c'était le petit bonhomme de
neige
l'humour donc voilà c'était mon petit
dessin animé pour toute la famille c'est
un film très agréable très sympathique
les acteurs aussi son bon après je
trouve qu'il ya des héros dit quand on a
vu les deux précédents il ya des thèmes
des longueurs alors c'est être un parti
pris de du réalisateur et moi ça va j'ai
des à ce niveau là c'est juste une
totale réussite
tout est réussi les dialogues
des acteurs le scénario il se permet
tout il ya des séquences animées
la musique est géniale même les gamins
sont criants de vérité
enfin c'est c'est parfait et je vous
propose pardon maintenant un retour dans
le passé les gants parfumé de
marie-antoinette remis au goût du jour
par un banquier installé à versailles en
plus il n'y en a que 36 exemplaires
approchez-vous et respirez vous ne
sentez rien c'est normal les odeurs ne
passe pas à la télévision dans second à
mieux pourtant se cachent des capsules
de talk qui contiennent du parfum pas
n'importe quel parfum celui que portait
marie antoinette
il y avait différents parfumeur qui
existait dans certains
qui était à qualité que pour la reine
marie antoinette l utiliser beaucoup de
fleurs douce mais elle aimait quand même
un petit peu d'acidité dans la fleur est
alors à le travailler beaucoup sur la
rose ce gant on le doit donc à olivier
fabre gantier depuis quatre générations
à millau est installé depuis peu à
versailles
on a cherché un modèle de gants que
porte et marie antoinette en
l'occurrence celui ci donc ce modèle de
gants en fait avait été vendue aux
enchères en 2005
et puis on a fait aussi un modèle
prestige le modèle trianon qui est un
modèle plus long et sur lequel on a fait
un motif d'un petit panier avec beaucoup
de roses on sait en fait inspirée d'une
robe que portait la reine et donc on a
fait ce banc second est entièrement fait
à la main c'est à dire qu'il faut à peu
près quatre à cinq jours pour fabriquer
une paire en broderie ou devant un vrai
retour aux sources quand on sait que le
parfum était d'abord utilisé dans les
gants catherine de médicis la première
lui a donné ses lettres de noblesse sous
louis xiv il ya eu là l'ordonance des
maîtres gantier parfumeur est donc cette
ordonnance en fait permettez à certaines
personnes de d'avoir pignon sur rue avec
des boutiques et tous les parfums à
l'intérieur qui était uniquement sur des
gants et quelques poudre et quelques lui
et c'est que sous louis 15 que
on est arrivés sur le parfum pour la
peau
36 paires de gants ont été réalisés pour
cette occasion élégant parfumé de
marie-antoinette ont déjà presque tous
trouvé la main qui département mais
avant de se quitter chevreuse maintenant
de jeter un coup d'oeil sur l'agenda de
ce week-end on va évidemment ça vous
intéresse aller du côté des marchés de
noël ce samedi et dimanche rendez vous
notamment a donc un saint cyr l'école au
gymnase jean macé mais également à
plaisir à la halle pardon du marché
c'est dans le centre-ville et puis si
vous voulez faire des cadeaux mais
également une belle action rendez vous à
la boutique emmaüs pour un noël
solidaire cet attrape ces samedi et
dimanche de 11h à 18h voilà je vous
souhaite un excellent week-end et je
vous dis à bientôt